un appel au calme je pense que je
comprends que des gens qui ont des
opinions différentes mais on peut
débattre de façon respectueuse
les québécois sont des gens accueillants
les québécois en droit de demander au
québec les personnes qui travaillent
pour le gouvernement qui sont en
autorités portent pas de signe religieux
c'est raisonnable s'est modérée on peut
être d'accord ou pas d'accord mais tu me
demandes qu'il estime ils sont nombreux
à dénoncer les propos du maire d'alfred
qui a fait allusion au nettoyage
ethnique en parlant du projet de loi sur
la laïcité des propos tenus vendredi
dernier
alors vous comprenez que le débat se
polarise autour de ce projet de loi
comme son scolaire municipalités
s'organisent ils ramènent des
manifestations je retrouve l'historien
sociologue gérard bouchard il a
coprésidé avec chastel la commission sur
les accommodements raisonnables publié
en 2008 dont soir monsieur bouchard
bonsoir madame dugenou depuis nos
studios de saguenay merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous avant de poursuivre
monsieur bouchard on va présenter à nos
à notre public un coup florilège qui
illustre bien l'état du débat en ce
moment on écoute je suis contre la loi
mais je vais jamais utilisé des propos
aussi incendiaire comme accusé monsieur
ce tie break je pense que c'est un
manque de jugement grave et il doit
s'excuser unis lui donc il ya des
responsabilités et il doit s'excuser
vous trouvez c'est l'état de la
situation depuis vendredi chez que vous
rentrez l'extérieur du pays monsieur
bouchard vous avez peut-être pas senti
la chaleur entourant ce débat depuis
quelques jours l'entente votre réaction
quand vous entendez ces propos là c'est
un maire
l'uda mme stead il est dénoncé par la
plupart des élus tout le monde veut que
s'excuser est loin de là ils récidivent
qu'est ce que vous en pensez votre
chance au bar très rapidement je trouve
que c'est pas vraiment surprenant dans
un débat comme celui ci qui survient
dans un contexte qui n'est pas nouveau
il ya déjà eu des précédents la charte
des valeurs etc
il ya des émotions qui sont encore très
vives il ya des cicatrices qui sont pas
refermées
je ne suis pas donc surpris d'une
intervention comme celle là mais d'un
autre côté on peut quasiment se réjouir
qu'il n'y en ait pas davantage
je pense pas que cette déclaration
reflète vraiment la lure du débat
présentement qui me paraît quand même
plus correct mais vous la lettre dénonce
évidemment cette déclaration oui
évidemment
évidemment bien sûr ce n'est pas fait
pour apaiser les esprits ni pour faire
avancer le débat
nous sommes d'accord il semble en tout
cas plus des manifestations
ce dimanche encore dernier puis aura de
nouvelles manifestations qui veulent
exprimer l'opposition de certaines
personnes je dis tout de suite monsieur
bouchard qu'on aura quelqu'un demain
l'émission qui défend le projet de loi
parce que c'est important d'avoir une
équité de points de vue à nexon pour ce
que vous aviez pas posé avec son compte
avec ne vont pas en fait je connaissais
tout l'éventail des propositions
alors je dis il ya des manifestations il
ya un discours qui qui se tient qui est
peut-être inquiétant
je vous fais entendre par exemple cette
femme de solidarité sans frontières
dimanche à la manifestation vous allez
l'entendre vous la verrez pas et soit
vous demander votre réaction
banyuls participera dit je cite tout
particulièrement les femmes musulmanes
est une expression dance hexis
islamophobes et antisémites
sa réussite est bienvenu le langage
parti compte la suprématie blanche
c'est particulièrement scandaleux que
les mêmes politiciens qui ont décoré le
massacre des gens
2010 est à la mosquée du québec
maintenant en place des lois qui vous
met en danger la vie des musulmans ne se
mouche a encore une fois votre réaction
le discours extrêmes bah c'est un peu
duel calibre que ce qu'on a entendu
juste avant c'est un peu moins pire mais
ces projections de l'intervention qu'on
souhaiterait je crois même pourquoi
pourquoi c'est comme ça pourquoi ce
qu'une femme prend la parole dans un
contexte la liberté d'expression peut
beaucoup choses il vient dire que c'est
un projet de loi qui met en danger la
vie des femmes musulmanes que ces
antisémites que cette islamophobe et
c'est alors que le gouvernement parle
ici de l'est hé oui mais nous sommes
bien d'accord on a tous ces propos sont
exagérées oui si on veut faire avancer
le débat il faut essayer de dalé ou de
l'or et puis après ça il faut quand même
se rendre compte comme monsieur legault
joue dans des eaux qui sont sulfureuse
nous savions ce débat il est ouvert
depuis une quinzaine d'années il a eu
plus de recul que d'avancer je pense que
nous sommes bien d'accord là dessus il
ya eu des antécédents qui ont laissé des
traces et des des blessures parmi
notamment les membres des minorités et
ses blessures n'a pas été guéri les
gouvernements ne souhaitons pas vraiment
démener pour restaurer les bons rapports
entre la majorité
culturel ou québec les minorités alors
forcément il ya des choses qui ont qu'on
a laissé traîner moi je crois que il ya
une piètre gouvernance des relations
interculturelles en rapport avec la
laïcité et autour de ces thèmes ça ne
justifie pas les propos que nous venons
d'entendre mais enfin il faut quand même
aussi regarder
ce que le gouvernement au fait et
comment il le fait moi je suis un peu
étonné de la façon dont monsieur legault
conçu et présenté ce projet qui jouent
dans des eaux sulfureuses
pour résumer rapidement pour le public
il ou non de la modération il propose
une chose grand-père donc les droits et
zaki bien sûr ils recourent à la
disposition dérogatoire mais il va jusqu
aux enseignants c'est un pas de plus par
rapport à ce qu'on a toujours appelé le
consensus vous chantez comme je parlais
des eaux sulfureuses je faisais allusion
aux débats que nous avons eus au cours
des dix dernières années où les 15
dernières années et qui ont donné lieu
déjà à des excès et qui ont laissé pas
mal de citoyens et de citoyennes
québécois ou québécoises dans une grande
insatisfaction pour employer un
euphémisme
maintenant regardez chez le groupe parle
de modération ça me surprend quand même
un peu parce que moi c'est justement ce
qui me gêne dans un projet dans son
projet de loi c'est l'absence de
modération
il me semble que c'est curieux à dire
mais il me semble que c'est un projet
qui ne ressemble pas aux québécois en
quoi il ressemble pas à l'idée que je me
fais des québécois et qu'il ressent pas
non plus à l'idée qu'on se faisait de
monsieur legault qui justement par assa
est un homme modéré ouvert aux autres
attentif sans simple même je dirais et
puis même prochaine comme ça n'est pas
exactement mais qu'est-ce que ça dans le
project qui par exemple comme chez le
dos quand monsieur legault parle d'un
bail hausse et donc il veut soustraire
le projet à la démocratie parlementaire
et quand ils recours à la clause
dérogatoire ce qu'il veut le soustraire
à l'examen des tribunaux et le projet en
lui-même prend de grandes libertés avec
les droits des personnes et même des
droits fondamentaux
il est possible illégitime il est même
légitime parfois de restreint d'un droit
ou même de le supprimer
à la condition d'avoir un motif
supérieur qui peut être reconnus par les
tribunaux
nascom si ce motif là
moi je ne le vois pas parce que par
exemple on entend souvent à propos des
hidjabs on entend dire que les femmes
qui le portent font du prosélytisme
auprès des élèves que le seul fait de
porter le hidjab est une forme
d'endoctrinement que le port du hidjab
et d autres signes religieux peut
traumatiser les élèves
mais rien de tout cela n'a été prouvée
et à ma connaissance il n'est même
jamais eu d'études qui ont été faites
pour appuyer des assertions comme celle
là qui aurait pu finalement salon les
résultats qu'on a rien obtenu car et
puis formez un motif vraiment
raisonnable que la cour aurait pu
reconnaître
j'ai même pas eu d'effort de ce côté là
c'est quand même un petit peu troublant
moi vous avez proposé un livre blanc
cela dit les défenseurs de la
proposition gouvernementale pour étendre
ce consensus des personnes en autorité
de coercition que vous aviez identifiés
dans votre rapport mais pour qui
d'ailleurs les opposants au projet de
loi se pose même à ce que vous aviez
proposé en disant que c'était n'y a pas
de fondement juridique plus à votre
formule qu'à celle qui est proposée par
les enseignants que au fond la
neutralité de l'état
je vais vous citer votre collègue
sociologue guy rocher un grand défenseur
de la laïcité au fondateur de la
révolution tranquille qui en 2010 signe
un texte avec d'autres intellectuels qui
disait la neutralité de l'état s'exprime
par la neutralité de l'image donnée par
ses représentants
ces derniers doivent donc éviter
d'afficher leur appartenance religieuse
philosophique et politique
et puis la joute l'école publique n'est
plus neutre si le corps enseignant les
membres de la direction affiche
ouvertement leur adhésion à une religion
est le terrorisme au fond est dit dans
le fond qu'un signe religieux pour les
enseignants et peut-être les directions
d'école c'est comme une vitrine dans le
fond d'une croyance religieuse et que
les les enfants dorment être à l'abri de
ça est ce que l'on peut penser
légitimement qui a un fondement pour
ceux qui croient ça mais moi je pense
qu'encore une fois ci c'est si c'est
dommageable pour les hits pour les
élèves pour les jeunes il faudra le
prouver
c'est peut-être probable c'est peut-être
raisonnable d'en faire une hypothèse
mais pour en faire un projet de loi et
qui transgressent ou suprême ou walter
des droits des personnes
il faut quand même avoir un fondement
plus solide il faudrait avoir des
données rigoureuses que nous n'avons pas
et en plus quand on en est pas que
l'argument de la laïcité mots je pense
qu'il ya peut être eu malentendu là
dessus moi je pense que quand au québec
les gens parlent de laïcité
il se réfère surtout à la séparation de
l'église et de l'état parce que celle ci
correspond à notre expérience depuis la
révolution tranquille et c'est ce qui
nous paraît le plus important mais la
laïcité et donc la séparation bien sûr
que c'est important parce que c'est
répartir les pouvoirs entre l'état et
les églises
mais en quoi est ce que le port de
signes religieux par des employés de
l'état pourrait compromettre cette
séparation
cliquez qui nous est si cher et avec
raison
ouais c'est ça c'est clair mais je ne le
vois pas qui le voit si vous voulez bien
je revois les à une brève pause monsieur
bush à qui on va poursuivre sur cette
lancée de la cola corrélation dont vous
que vous ne voyez pas mais que d'autres
voient enfin la pause merci
[Musique]
projet de loi sur la laïcité je
poursuive et historien sociologue gérard
bouchard monsieur bouchard jose avant la
pause on parlait donc on parlait donc de
cette séparation de l'état avec le
religieux
deux camps s'opposent ici dans ce
débat-là et l'étonnant la laïcité estime
que justement la veste et le meilleur
espace pour assurer l'égalité notamment
des femmes et assure le meilleur espace
pour l'expression de la pluralité du
pluralisme
entendez vous aussi vos chats
oui je vous entends mais ça me paraît ça
me paraît contraire que que
l'interdiction de porter des signes
religieux est un moyen de favoriser le
pluralisme ce sera plutôt le contraire
un moyen de favoriser le mot gênés it et
l'uniformité
en même temps si ces deux points de vue
là s'affrontent en ce moment lorsque
c'est aussi le point de vue du
gouvernement s'appuyant sans fondement
passe pas c'est dur la majorité des
québécois veut ça c'est l'aboutissement
de la révolution tranquille
par ailleurs les gens disent non c'est
discrimatoires ces islamophobes et
cetera
comment comment on peut sortir de ce 1
des même si on peut de sept de ses
débats lors de cette crise là cependant
d'abord dire que s'appuyer sur le
majorité de la population en matière de
droit c'est pas toujours un bon argument
parce que la majorité peut se tromper et
surtout quand il s'agit des droits des
minorités et c'est pour ça qu'il ya des
tribunaux et des arbitres qui sont
indépendants du législateur et à mon
avis c'est pas pour rien que monsieur
legault veut recourir à la clause
nonobstant c'est probablement exactement
pour cette raison comment en sortir
ça paraît très difficile dans l'état
actuel parce que ce ce projet d'une
certaine manière me paraît radical le
parti radical parce que il n'arrive pas
à fournir l'argument d'un motif
supérieur que les tribunaux pourraient
reconnaître il soustrait encore une fois
à la justice en recourant à la clause
nonobstant et il s'apprête même à la
soustraire encore une fois la discussion
démocratique en recours au bâillon
ça fait beaucoup de choses à l'ambition
c'est une simple qu'au québec on n'est
pas une société comme ça on est une
société qui est soucieuse compromis de
débats de 2
nous semblons les plus sensibles que ça
et qu'on évite en général le radicalisme
dans l'histoire du québec toutes les
tentatives qui ont eu recours au
radicalisme sont échoués n'ont pas duré
longtemps on peut prendre quatre ou cinq
exemples c'est contraire à notre culture
politique mais ouais mais même temps le
compromis ce qu'on appelle consensus
vous chantez votre collègue la run il
dit même aujourd'hui qu'il a honte
d'être québécois vous est ce que vous
considérez que votre consensus de
l'époque en 2008 est toujours viable
parce que pour certains ils n'avaient
pas plus de fondement je lui dis que la
question des affaires oui mais pour moi
il a un fondement juridique
c'est à dire c'est pour favoriser un
meilleur exercice de la justice
en instaurant plus de confiance parmi
les justiciers parmi les gens qui sont
victimes
avec raison peut-être dès qu'ils ont
commis les transgressions et c'est bon
et à ce moment là d'avoir une comme une
confiance absolue dans les magistrats ou
dans les policiers c'était quand même
une donnée qui est fondamentale et moi
il me semble que la mesure que je
propose vote dans ce sens-là d'améliorer
l'image d'indépendance d'impartialité de
neutralité de crédibilité des magistrats
et des autres avions qui exerce un
pouvoir exceptionnel malone dû sauter le
pouvoir de frapper des citoyens de les
emprisonner et ses pendants
alors moi ce n'est pas vraiment dans
l'esprit d'un compromis moi que je tiens
à cette formule c'est qu'elle me paraît
justement justiciable devant les
tribunaux et si jamais elle devait être
approuvée ou adoptés par un gouvernement
évidemment l'étape suivante sera de la
soumettre aux tribunaux et à ce moment
là si elle est pas que la table on le
verra puis on passera à autre chose
ouais mais évidemment les gens je prend
le contrepied de votre discours
évidemment c'est mon rôle de le faire
les tonalités disent évidemment en
matière de signes religieux qu'est ce
qu'ils disent est ce que c'est le québec
parce que la question de priver des
personnes d'un emploi est ce que le
québec c'est lui qui dicte vraiment une
conduite aussi plutôt la religion et le
québec a son histoire face à laval
ils ont enfin débarrassé en ville mais
plusieurs depuis le depuis 50 ans et il
ya comme une histoire au québec un
rapport à la religion qui fait que les
autres cultures pour être capté à
comprendre cette histoire du québec non
mais oui bien sûr c'est ce dont nous
parlions tout à l'heure et c'est pour ça
que nous sommes si attachés à la
séparation de l'église et de l'état mais
encore une fois pour moi il n'est pas
évident que l'idée de cette séparation
des pouvoirs sa compagne d'un corollaire
qui consiste à interdire les employés de
l'état à porter des signes religieux je
crois pas je vois pas en quoi ça affecte
ou que ça altère le principe de la
séparation de l'église et de l'état où
la séparation des pouvoirs
par exemple pour les enseignants même
les enseignants de les cours d'éthique
et de culture religieuse ne peuvent pas
affirmer une religion plus qu'une autre
on est des confessions et les télécoms
sont scolaire les écoles nous
religieuses et religieux ce sont les 6
et dans les années 60
est-ce que c'est pas le prolongement
normal de cette volonté de laïcité de
l'incarner à travers les enseignants
vient du sections importantes à faire
madame du show dans les à partir des
années 60 les religieux les religieuses
se sont laïcisé en ce sens que ce sont
des faits des signes religieux c'est ce
que vous voulez dire oui oui mais l'ont
fait parce qu'ils ont voulu le faire
elles ont décidé de le faire personne ne
leur en imposer
s'il avait voulu garder leurs signes
religieux et leurs effets et nous
aurions continué à vivre avec soi sans
difficulté je crois le gouvernement face
au bail on n'a pas ça pourrait changer
pourrait y avoir un débat au fond s'il y
avait un débat en profondeur comme sens
que comme si on parlementaires ouvertes
et prendre le temps d'en débattre déjà
ce que ce serait intéressant pour vous
comme ouverture moi je pense que dans
les conditions actuelles
le débat est il est un peu verrouillé
par si encore une fois il me semble que
ce projet de loi
ne repose pas sur des données qui en
établissent la légitimité autrement que
de dire nous voulons la laïcité c'est
une tradition dans l'histoire du québec
nous avons eu des rapports difficiles
avec la religion y est parfaitement vrai
mais encore une fois il ya aussi les
droits des personnes dont il faut tenir
compte et la ja oui je dirais je vais
employer le mot il ya un compromis à
établir il ya une position le qu'il
faudrait trouver qui est pas forcément
la mienne
d'après la loi on pourrait l'imaginer
dos mais je ne sais pas moi j'ai
réfléchi j'en ai conçu une pour moi je
vais pas travailler en consomme bordeaux
mais il pourrait certainement y avoir
d'autres je ne prends pas pour les es
vraiment chercher parce que le parti
libéral prend une position qui est le
libéralisme classique c'est à dire que
la liberté des individus doit prévaloir
sur les instances où certaines instances
de l'état et donc les droits sont
presque absolu donc ça conduit à la
position du parti libéral la charte du
parti québécois allaient à mon avis
beaucoup trop loin dans l'autre
direction
québec solidaire vient d'adopter la
position du parti libéral donc ils
s'arrangent aussi dans une forme
je ne dirais pas de radicalisme et pas
loin c'est à dire que là on ne peut plus
discuter et puis monsieur legault il va
trop loin aussi je pense que c'est un
projet de loi qui n'est pas en accord
avec notre culture politique et moi si
la discussion doit s'ouvrir c'est les
conditions d'un véritable débat avec des
chances d'aboutir doivent être définis
mais il faudrait que monsieur legault
redéfinir son projet en enlevant la
question des enseignants en promettant
et des bas et en enlevant la dose dans
le fond en enlevant ainsi la disposition
dérogatoire si ces trois éléments là
vous demander bah oui à mon avis moi je
crois qu'ils devraient se soustraire les
enseignants à sa loi qui devrait
annulé le recours à la clause
dérogatoire parce que moi c'est quelque
chose qui me gêne énormément de
soustraire des décisions du parlement en
matière de suppressions de droits à
l'examen par les tribunaux je trouve ça
extrêmement jeune homme toute la
question repose évidemment sur le
respect des droits individuels et les
droits collectifs ici oui mais justement
le droit de débattre et de demander
l'avis des instances qui ont mis sur
pied
justement pour exercer cette fonction
c'est à dire les tribunaux ça fait
partie des droits collectifs aussi
madame du show là dessus monsieur
bouchard
merci nous n'avons parlé ce soir est ce
que ça veut dire que vous allez vous
engager davantage dans des bornes super
u n'a cessé de le faire depuis quelques
années la promet de continuer à le faire
aller vous faire vous aussi non je
donnais cette entrevue parce que
j'estimais que je voulais devrais je
vais peut-être en donner une autre mais
ça n'ira pas plus loin de toute façon
des positions sont bien connus et encore
une fois il me semble que dans les
conditions actuelles le débat est un peu
cadenassé et que à mon avis ça va se
terminer par un tour de force et
monsieur des voeux monsieur legault
utilise souvent l'argument que enfin ça
va mettre fin au débat alors qui est en
train de prendre les mesures pour
justement leur lancée pendant quelques
années j'ai la bouche à merci beaucoup
depuis saguenay j'allais dire chicoutimi
de nous avoir parlé ce soir
merci beaucoup diversifiés tant que
j'avais compris par les merci au revoir
au revoir